Speaker 1: Let's go next to Quentin from Portland.
Is that Portland, Maine, or Portland, Oregon?
Quinton Portland. Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Oh, Portland,
Oregon. Beautiful. So I had a conversation
with my mother, who was extremely, extremely
right wing. Okay. And she was blaming the lefties
or the Dems or the Libs know whatever she wants
to say about leaking the Supreme Court document,
by the way. And I didn't really have a rebuttal
saying that, like I've heard you say that it's
more likely a right leaning person leaked it,
but I couldn't really clearly tell her why I have
that opinion. So if you could just clear that up,
I'd really appreciate it. And then.
Speaker 1: Well, okay, let's take it piece
by piece, then I'll get to your second question.
So to be clear, what I've said before is in terms
of just plausibility, it's equally plausible
that a left winger or a right winger leaked the
Supreme Court decision. You could say, well, it's
a left winger who wanted to try to create outrage,
to have pressure on the judges to change their
votes and end up maintaining Roe v Wade. Or you
could say it's a right winger who decided to leak
it out of fear that some of the justices planning
to overturn Roe v Wade might change their minds
to put pressure on them to maintain the positions
they had in the February draft. So plausibility
is kind of equal. But we have some reporting from
long time Supreme Court reporters, including from
NPR, who say that the overarching belief within
the court right now is that the leaker was a right
winger, but ultimately, we don't know. So what I
would ask is what evidence do you have to support
that the leaker was left wing? I would go with
that. And of course, there is no such evidence.
Speaker 2: Yeah, on a number of issues. That's
kind of my response. Okay. Yeah. And then also,
please just Google Josh Dallas on your show. You
look like you are him. Oh, I've.
Speaker 1: Been told that before.
He's an actor, right?
Speaker 2: Yes, he's an
actor. You're you're slightly better looking.
But, yeah, I mean, you guys, it's uncanny.
Speaker 1: I'm only slightly better
looking. Oh, boy. All right, well,
I'll take it as a compliment anyway.
Speaker 2: All right. Well, thank you,
David. I appreciate it. All right.
Speaker 1: Thank you so much for the call.
Very, very important stuff there.